at least six police officers have been
killed in a bomb attack in Northwestern
Pakistan now they've been assigned to
protect workers carrying out a polio
immunization campaign the attack was
carried out near the border with
Afghanistan in Mund the Pakistani
Taliban has claimed responsibility that
polio vaccination drives in Pakistan are
regularly marred by violence Pakistan
and Afghanistan are the only countries
in the world where polio remains
emic it's our responsibility to provide
police security to every polio
vaccination team whether it consists of
two people or one we send the security
from here to far flung places today they
targeted the police
truck San Saladin is the director of the
center for regional and Global
connectivity at the Tad lab Think Tank
he joins us now live from the Pakistani
Capital Islam Abad good of you to join
us on the program sir the ongoing
attacks on medical workers trying to
immunize those against polio continue
but
why well there's lots of reasons for
that sah the principal reason among them
is the fact that when polio campaigns do
happen a lot of these groops are vying
for legitimacy they want to demonstrate
their strike capability they want to
showcase the fact they have access to
various parts of the country to be able
to wreak havoc and conduct their violent
operations the polio teams are
especially vulnerable because when the
polio campaigns happen across Pakistan
and as you said Pakistan and Afghanistan
are the only two polio mic countries
left in the world close to 300,000
people are deployed across the country
to vaccinate millions of children all at
the same time within about a two to
three day window now during that time
there are police officers and law
enforcement officials that are assigned
to these teams to protect them but they
are soft targets because to conduct a
quick driveby shooting in which you end
up injuring and or killing the polio
workers or police is a fairly easy thing
to do the second reason is uh what we're
doing right now so they know that polio
is still a very important topic for news
media outlets around the world and if
they conduct these kinds of attacks
channels like your esteem Channel AA
itself will interview people like me uh
in order to ascertain the situation and
determine what might be the root causes
and this of course will give them
exposure and further establish their
legitimacy and the third and perhaps a
more dormant reason now is the fact that
since the killing of Usama bin ladin in
2011 which was conducted after a local
doctor Dr Shaquil AFI identified him
having been embedded in a local NGO
there was a narrative spun by violent
quarters within Pakistan that certain
NOS had been infiltrated by spy networks
and that narrative the vestages of it at
the very least we still see particularly
in and bistan the two provinces that
suffer from violence the most so who
actually gains the most then really from
these sorts of attacks because as you
say there can be elements of uh
desperate minority uh political armed
groups that might benefit from this but
at the end of the day you know polio is
a very visible um ailment when it hits
the human body and any parent wouldn't
want to see their child in that
situation absolutely but you have to
understand that the narrative that is
spun is also created in areas that are
very far-flung very remote where
literacy rates are very low and where
penetration by groups like the Taliban
Pakistan that's the Pakistani Taliban
can be in certain areas quite High the
net result of course of all this is that
people in these areas can be convinced
of certain narratives that may or may
not be directly at odds with their
children's health so for example one of
the narratives that has been spun
particularly in the tribal Bel since
June of 2014 has been the fact that in
these areas social infrastructure is is
limited education is practically
non-existent the healthcare
infrastructure and the legal Frameworks
do not extend to these areas in all uh
in every sense of the word the social
contract is not being fulfilled by the
state however there's this very
expensive vaccine that ends up showing
up at their doors consistently every
three months and that leads to a certain
rise in the level of Suspicion and that
has been spun by these groups as grounds
for rejecting these vaccines under the
under the uh narrative that they will
turn your children infertile now anyone
who's actually studying the growth rate
in Pakistan will tell you that
Pakistan's population has increased now
to 240 m 1 million as of the digital
census released uh in the middle of last
year but that doesn't really stop people
from remote in remote areas to be
indoctrinated by this very compelling
narrative and what's left is an ailing
Health Service protected by elements
either of the police service or the
military to get children vaccinated
what's really needed is strong
government the problem is Pakistan
doesn't have strong government the
Senate has postponed elections that
should have been destined for February
the 8th what it needs is a strong Health
Minister and Direction and Pakistan
hasn't really had that with the ups and
downs of the of the political uh circus
that's been going on these past few
years absolutely the two existential
problems Pakistan that exist right now
are its economy and its climate change
and despite that uh there's a Gallop
poll that was released yesterday that
said that across most news organizations
and political pundit shows in the
evenings 59% of coverage was actually
given to political drama in the country
if you speak to any entities whether
they be inside Pakistan or outside of
Pakistan the one thing that they label
as absolutely necessary for Pakistan to
progress and for them to interact
positively with Pakistan is political
and policy continuity so in that you're
absolutely right in that we do need a
direction from a strong Health Minister
but what I will say here sahale is that
that polio program which is supported by
UNICEF wh funded in part by the bill and
Lind Gates Foundation and a range of
other actors including District
hospitals uh administrations and
provincial uh subjects is actually a
very comprehensive campaign the real
problem here is that attacks that are
conducted on the polio teams are very
very difficult to actually counter by
Security Forces simply because even if
you were to double up or triple up the
number of uh law enforcement uh
officials that might be guarding these
teams to conduct and to cordon off an
entire area and conduct a polio campaign
in that area is still susceptible to a
lone wolf attacker and this is
consistently what we have seen happen on
during the polio attacks across the
country since as early as 2014 zishan
Sal it's been good to get your insight
into the story certainly for our
International viewers thanks for joining
us from Islam about thank you for having
me